hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game app from The Havana Tournament
of 1965. it's not actually called that
it's the capablanca Memorial tournament
the fourth capablanca Memorial and one
of the players that was invited to the
tournament was uh none other than Robert
James Fisher uh it is uh it marks the
first appearance of Fisher since the
Curacao Canada's Tournament of 1962. we
haven't covered it in the Bobby
Fischer's Saga but maybe you guys
remember that fisher accused the Soviet
players of colluding with each other and
uh well sort of robbing him of winning
the the candidates tournament he said
that okay that would they would just get
quick draws against each other uh then
they would push one of them to the top
and they would all play their absolute
best against him so chances of him
winning were well not not as great as
you know if it were a fair tournament
but okay that was in 1962 this is 1965
and
Fisher was invited by by Fidel Castro
himself it was organized under the
patronage of Che Guevara and they all
offered three thousand dollars for first
place in this tournament then they said
okay we could maybe spend maybe four and
a half five thousand dollars uh
depending on how the other players rank
in the tournament but Fisher requested
uh just for uh showing up just a
participation fee of three thousand
dollars so he wanted his participation
fee to equal that of actually winning
the tournament and they gladly accepted
however Fisher was not granted a visa to
visit uh Havana and play the tournament
but then uh he got an idea or maybe he
didn't get the idea I think the idea was
maybe just attributed to him maybe some
uh someone else came up with it uh he I
said okay I'll I'll just play it via a
Telex machine and I'm gonna tell it's
the moose and uh we're gonna play like
that I'm gonna play from the New York
chess club and uh you know if you guys
are okay with that he would be happy to
play that way and they did accept this
for those of you who don't know what a
Telex machine is uh this is the Telex
machine it's sort of a
you know some uh basically technology
that was used
um uh sometimes in the 80s it's uh the
Telex network is a Station to Station
switch network of teleprinters similar
to a telephone network using Telegraph
great connection uh connecting circuits
for two-way text based messages Telex
was a major method of sending written
messages electronically between
businesses in the post-world War II
period its usage went into decline as
the fax machine grew in popularity in
the 1980s so there you have it basically
a definition from Wikipedia they of
course didn't use this exact same one
they used the one uh I don't know it's
not even the thumbnail I don't think we
have a photo of the one they used but
the board that fisher used at uh you
know uh Play Over the moves that were
sent to him via the Telex machine is
still I believe present in the Manhattan
chess club so if you are from there or
if you are just visiting you will be
able to see this board that feature used
to play this tournament I don't know if
it was used to play the entire
tournament but it was definitely used to
play this game against mislav uh which
is
um any a very important game for this
tournament I will mention up front uh
vaselism uh won the tournament
um but uh also one of the reasons why
this is such an incredible game so let's
check it out and then we're going to
discuss it a little bit more uh Fisher
has the white pieces and he opens with
Ponte E4 and this is uh only round two
of the tournament so many more runs to
be played you want to do really well and
okay you can take a a you know a little
bit of chances it's not like it's the
last round and you have to be uh uh you
know playing for a draw or something
like that and okay missile replies with
E5 we have Knight to F3 Knight to C6 and
Bishop to B5 Fisher goes for the uruil
Lopez with A6 morphe's defense by Smith
and Bishop to A4 we have Knight to F6
and now uh Fisher played Pawn to D3 now
in those three years that we mentioned
that fisher did not play a single game
in the International Tournament after
the Curacao candidates Fisher did a lot
of studying on chess and he well was
very much inspired by none other than
the first world champion Wilhelm steinit
who was a big fan of this D3 move and
pretty much from the era of Wilhelm
Stein it's up until this point no one
ever used it they thought it was uh they
thought it was a slower move a weaker
move that white just gives up his
Advantage but Fisher thought it
differently he thought that Stanis had a
great idea and that this is in fact an
incredibly strong move and today it is
of course Very Much played castles and
D3 are the top moves in the position and
here uh well D6 was played by Smith's
love and Fisher said that he didn't like
this that this was very much passive for
black that fisher preferred to some like
Pawn to B5 and after the bishop moves
the bishop B7 then okay white goes after
the flank with A4 and so on or even uh
you during the famous match as we've
also covered that in the morphe Saga
this is the position from the morphy
Anderson game
uh where uh Pawn to B5 was played by the
First bishop to C5 by morphe Anderson
continued with C3 then Pawn to B5 then
Bishop to B3 uh both morphine Anderson
castled and now uh morphe uh struck in
the center with the five characters
captures and black has a very active
game yeah you you should be very happy
with your position here but okay Smith
still played D6 it's not terrible or
anything Fisher just says okay maybe you
could play a little bit more active C3
uh freeing up the C2 Square for the
bishop if needed and not Bishop to E7
with Knight B to D2 castles and Knight
to F1 these are all very standard moves
but of course this was played in
1965 so uh even though they are they are
very standard uh there weren't as many
games played in this line back then and
the idea is okay you could maybe just
move the knight in Castle or if uh black
allows it you already have a very nice
Bishop you could place it here or you
could place on this diagonal you could
play h3g4 put the knight in G3 postpone
castling and just go for a for a brutal
King side attack so Smith's law went B5
with Bishop to B3 and now uh he played
Pawn to D5 sort of mixing the line that
morphe played uh but not really Fisher
says that D5 here is just uh not uh
not the best because you already played
D6 you don't want to waste more time by
playing D5 here if you just continue
with the standard chasing of the Bush of
Knight F5 Bishop C2 then you play C5 and
so on but with Pawn to D5 and now Fisher
goes Queen to E2 with d captures on e4
and now D captures an E4 with Bishop to
E6 offering a trade of Bishops and
Fisher said that he was very surprised
by this that missile would allow the
doubling of the of the pawns as for
those of you who are maybe new to chess
vaselism is a former world champion I
did not mention this as I'm uh you know
I think of course everyone knows this uh
but yeah he was an incredibly strong
player and he still is like I said he
won this tournament so Fisher said all
right I can double his pawns but it's
probably not as relevant I mean if it
was missile would never allow it so
Bishop captures an E6 F captures and now
Knights the G3 now Fisher says as uh uh
I I am operating uh with a lot of
comments by Fisher himself he did cover
this game in his book my my 60 memorable
games so we have a lot of um uh input
from Bobby himself uh and now he says
all right the Knight probably won't be
able to stay there because the pawn now
is nicely covering this the Knight is
nicely covering H5 but we're gonna
Castle we're gonna move the Rook we're
gonna re-maneuver the Knight and then
the Knight will be back in the game and
here we have Queen to D7 and it is now
as of move 13 that this position has
never been reached again so let's see
how Fisher continues we have castles and
Rook 8 to d8 and here Fisher says that
oh now I realize what Miss Love is doing
he's well he wants to play Queen to D3
and just trade Queens and with the
queens of the board it's gonna be much
much harder to hone in on this double e
Pawn weakness and okay Fisher plays A4
very standard move you want to attack
the flank here we have Queen to D3 and
Fisher traits we have captors captures
and now a capture Sun B5 a captors and
now if Smith was allowed this bishop to
C5 move then he would have no problems
but Fisher is not about to allow it he
plays a rook to A6 now he attacks the
Knight and the Knight cannot move as the
pawn on E6 would be hanging so here we
have Rook back to D6 now the bishop must
remain an E7 and now Fisher continues
with his plan uh King the H1 now uh the
idea behind King the H1 is that uh Smith
still would very much enjoy playing this
freeing move Knights to D4 to give you
an example let's say B4 is played and B4
is the the best move pretty much in any
position and not just that uh in this
game B4 really is the best move in any
position for white and black and you you
will see what I mean by this Smith even
says this exact same thing after the
game but here the problem would be
Knight D4 now attacks The Rook but also
threatens Knight captures on F3 which
comes with check and here you would just
be able to trade too much material
Knight captures an F3 with check G
captures Bishop captures and you've sold
all of your problems so a black is very
very much okay here so instead King the
H1 by Fisher first stopping any Knight
to D4 ideas and now we have Knight to D7
and the Fisher says that uh he was uh he
was pretty sure that missile would play
B4 here and he was also sure that he
should play B4 here because uh it's just
I mean uh it's the only move that black
has ended with white playing B4 uh White
um uh just uh you know Rob's black of
the only move he has but the problem was
Fisher thought that maybe it would
weaken C3 too much maybe if we can see
for too much and Smith thought that
maybe if he plays B4 then here we can
see Ford then maybe Fisher can put a
knight and C4 put more pressure on E5
and so on so none of them actually
touched the B4 Square so here we have
Knights the D7 by Smith and now Bishop
to E3 uh controlling the the C5 Square
we have rooked d8 and now H3 with Ponte
H6 and now Rook F the A1 doubling up on
the a file and now as missile goes for
Knight D to B8 uh kicks away The Rook we
have Rook to A8 and now Rooks the D1
check Smith trades off a pair of rocks
and Fisher doesn't like Trading right
away because if he trades right away
captures captures with check then
something like King to F7 and black is
doing fine here so instead Fisher just
plays King the H do forces missile of
the Capron A1 so Rook captures with Rook
captures and now Knight to D7 and here
is uh probably Smith's last opportunity
to play Pawn to B4 you really want to
play this move but he played Knight to
D7 like I said he didn't want to allow
Knight to D to the C4 to put more
pressure on E5 but it cannot be avoided
and now Fisher plays it himself Pawn to
B4 and now you will see just how
difficult it is for uh missile to figure
out what to play with King to F7 now
Knight to F1 now the idea is of course
the Knight is coming to D2 then the B3
then to C5 or if C4 can be played maybe
C4 the Knight comes to C4 and so on so
Bishop to D6 adds more defense than the
E5 pawn and now Pawn to G3 it seems like
a waste of time or something thing but
there's no time to waste here Fisher has
all the time in the world and G3 is
crucial to properly continuing this game
the problem is if you if you play let's
say Knight one to D2 continuing with
your plan you again allow this weird
Knight to D4 move and here the problem
is of course okay now we capture C
captures e captures and D4 comes with a
discovery and then after let's say E5
everything gets traded off D captures
and E3 ecaptress and D6 you're going to
capture the Knight here D captures and
C7 attacks The Rook you're gonna attack
The Rook Knight captures on D2 Rook
captures on C7 and they're the draw
equal material we've traded off
everything nothing to look forward to
here so instead Fisher played Pawn to G3
and now uh this diagonal is forever
closed and the dreams of playing Knight
to D4 no longer uh exist with Knight to
F6 and now putting pressure on e4 just
Knight one to D2 defending it with King
to E7 and now Rook the A6 again putting
pressure on the Knight here making it a
very difficult for a Smith to defend now
one thing that you could consider is
King the D7 Fisher or even mentions this
in his book but it's such a weird idea
King the seventh Knight to E1 now Knight
to B8 kicking away the rook and after
The Rook attack is the Pawn King to C6
but this looks like such a weird Square
uh to put your King on I mean the the
Knight will come to D3 the other night
the B3 it's very hard to imagine the the
black kings the remain here unharmed so
instead we have Knights the B8 attacking
The Rook Rook to A5 and now
uh we have Pawn to C6 this is again a
weakening of the position uh but what
are you gonna do there is one thing okay
Knight to C6 maybe you could sacrifice
the B5 pawn and then play Rook day eight
you give up the pawn to win the file
then you can use the a file that uh
maybe put some pressure on the on the
white king uh but you already have The
Double E Pawn if you if you're
sacrificing a pawn make it make it the
double Pawn don't give up the healthy B
Pawn uh but okay after Rook a five we
have Pawn to C6 and now we have King to
G2 now the idea is to bring the king
over to e to put the Knight on D3 and uh
continue on improving the position we
have Knight beat the D7 and the King to
F1 not a lot for us miss love to do here
uh we have uh rooked the C8 here again
Fisher thought that maybe missile will
go for Knight to E8 to C7 guards the a
square and then try to trade off Rooks
with Rook day eight but no he just goes
Rook to C8 uh and Fisher goes Knight to
E1 and now Knight the E8 now uh missile
goes for it but Fisher says that it is
my much too late and the problem is if
you play C5 here okay it's upon
sacrifice but not one that does all that
much Fisher would remain with the past B
Pawn and this is uh well in Fisher's
hands this is winning so instead
Knight's the E8 we have Knights to D3
and now Knights the C7 hoping to get
Rook to a18 but Fisher uh uh prevents
this by playing the the move you thought
that was never going to be played here
and that is Pawn to C4 a very very
strong point is that now if Rook day
displayed C5 traps the bishop on D6 so
Smith cannot allow this he has to react
and pretty much your only move is uh
capturing or you know you play something
like Knight back T8 but your knight came
from there okay you will free up this
diagonal for the bishop it's not great
so B captures in C4 Knight captures and
C4 now puts even more pressure on this
Pawn
uh and now we have Knight to B5 uh the
problem is if you go Rook to A8 now it's
it's a very simple real captures Knight
captures now you're gonna play Knight to
A5 you go after the pawn and look at the
passive Knights you have to play Knights
the B8 to defend the pawn now you play
Bishop to A7 you threaten the kick away
at the uh capture the Knight and then
win the pawn and after the king defends
with King 37 you will play Knight back
to C4 and there is no defending the E5
Pawn then you pick off the E5 point then
you play f for E5 you grab more space
you win the game so that's how Fisher
sees it so Knights to be five by Smith's
love and now Rook the A6 just again
keeping all the tension not allowing uh
Smith of the to even find a square for
any of his pieces uh as myself plays uh
King to F6 now the problem is if you go
for Knight to B8 which can be played uh
look at this Rook to A8 and now after
Knight the C7
attacking The Rook Fisher says Knight
captures and D6 and it's game over as
the rook and C8 is hanging and after
King captures you can just play Bishop
to C5 check now you will pick up the
five Pawn with check as well and after
King d8 you will just play Rook to A7 uh
keep your extra pawn and uh well it's
just too passive a position the Knight
bishop and Rook combo are too deadly to
deal with so instead after Rook a 6 King
the F6 was played by Smith and now okay
you are attacking the pawn with the both
of the knights but now it's time to
bring in more Firepower uh Bishop to C1
now the bishop is coming to B2 and then
of course F4 will be played and there
will be no no saving the pawn so Bishop
to B8 uh and now Bishop to B2 and Smith
is officially out of moves he plays Pawn
to C5 the idea is okay maybe if Fisher
starts F4 then Smith can play C capture
some B4 and then okay the Knight will
not be able to capture back the Knight
will be needed to help out with the E5
square but as Fisher says in his book it
is a desperate bid for counter play so
Knights the B6 uh stopping all of this
now The Rook is hanging and there is no
way to handle this Knight captures on B6
Rook captures and here okay the problem
is you play Knights the D4 dangerous
Knight captures on C5 and that's pretty
much it uh the the past B phone will be
too powerful uh also the Knight cannot
move the E6 the E6 Pawn is hanging or
you're just gonna capture it and then
pick up the E6 Pawn so uh impossible to
play so instead C4 was played by Smith's
love Fisher played Knight to C5 and here
Smith will play he actually played the
strongest move recommended by the engine
C3 and here the game was adjourned to be
continued uh another day as you know in
the olden days games were adjourned
there were no chess engine so you could
not cheat with an engine at home but uh
Smith did not continue this game uh
Smith
resigned and he said that he wanted to
congratulate Fisher personally uh so he
he he called him via telephone and he
said that okay congratulations on
playing a beautiful active brilliant
brilliant game and both Fisher and him
agreed that yeah it was all due to him
not playing Ponte B4
um and yeah Smith even attributed his
loss to you know to his reluctance to
play Pawn to be for so that that's just
how important the B4 square is
especially when you play uh such a such
a strict positional game and here as
middle of course resigned because there
is nothing to play here I mean uh if if
he didn't play this Pawn to C3 move what
can he play the Knight here is hanging
he can play Knight to C7 but then just
Knight the D7 check and you lose the
bishop the King has to move you're gonna
pick up the bishop here and that's
pretty much it here after Pawn to C3
it's pretty it's the exact same thing
because after uh Fisher let's say play
spawn to C1 the Knight is still hanging
You're Gonna Play Knight to D4 but not
just root capture some B8 that's it real
characters Knight to D7 check uh with a
Fork here King D7 Knight captures and uh
that's all there is
uh so yeah after C3 official won This
brilliant game and even though this was
a very important win for Fisher against
the former world champion in only round
two of the capablanca Memorial
tournament uh it was uh it was Miss Love
who won the entire thing here are the
standings of the tournament um
as you can see Smithville won the
tournament with 15 and a half out of 21
with 13 wins and three losses and second
place shared with uh by Boris laview
effing dealer and Robert James Fisher
now uh although we all love Bobby
Fischer so much that we covered this
tournament uh by talking about Fisher or
we talk about Smith's love or we maybe
talk about General things like that but
this was in fact it was this was
supposed to be borislav ifkov's
tournament uh he had a brilliant
tournament he was leading for the entire
tournament and uh going up into the
final two games in the penultimate round
he lost Gilberto Garcia who as you can
see got last place in the tournament uh
one of his wins was against none other
than Morris love evco he played a
terrible blunder one unfitting even uh
1600 player and I mean it it completely
broke him uh he lost that game and then
he lost
the final uh game as well I think
against Cuomo or or Pacman or maybe even
against I think he lost the robot in the
final round and yeah it was supposed to
be his tournament but it just wasn't you
know that's also one of uh one of the
things that you have to be able to do
not just play one game great not just
play two games not just ten but you have
to be able to play all of them uh in the
tournament with the exact same strength
something that Bobby Fischer could do
something obviously Smith could do and
that's why they won tournaments uh but
yeah uh just one of the games uh that uh
I wanted to show you really a true
positional brilliance by Bobby Fischer
uh we're probably gonna check out some
other games from this tournament not
just Fisher's games so we're gonna cover
some other games as well as I've never
covered a single game from this
tournament because we've skipped
basically we mentioned the Curacao
candidates tournament we've skipped all
of this uh you know and we've went
straight into the uh 1950 and 1959 us uh
Championship that went you know to the
uh interzonal Tournament of Palma de
mayorca then into the candidates matches
and that's how we basically started and
ended the Bobby Fischer Saga but yeah
this is a beautiful tournament I'm gonna
cover some games maybe even a lot of
them while I'm still preparing the shiny
Saga but yeah you can see how even even
the great Bobby Fisher was influenced by
wilheim Stein it's he employed D3 here
against mislav and Smith love just
wasn't uh ready for it D3 I mean such a
docile looking move but uh you know it
takes it took the uh the the great
former World Champion by surprise and he
just didn't find a great way of of
Defending he tried the bishop to E6 he
doubled his pawns uh and okay it was uh
possible to do this for for some time
but in the end Fisher just broke him and
this is something that Affairs opponent
said about the Bobby Fischer playing
against him it's like being in a room
with walls just closing in on you and
there's no way out there are no doors
there are no windows and the walls will
just continue closing in and that's
pretty much what happened in this game
so yeah if you have any game of your uh
choosing that you would like to see from
this tournament to use hashtag
suggestion and I will show it but like I
said I'm probably going to show many
more games from this tournament seems
like a lovely tournament to check out uh
so yeah that's the game I hope you guys
enjoyed it I would like to thank
Federico Torres physalco Dan McCormick
James Eugene Cashman Engel Musa and
Pedro Baldo for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here and thank you
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day